Okay, hi, everyone.
I'm going to dive straight in.
Custom properties are now supported in all
modern browsers, and this is great.
It means we are starting to see examples of
people using them in production.
But they're different from variables in preprocessors.
And I've already seen a lot of examples where
people are using them in a similar way without
necessarily considering what specific advantages
they have to offer.
That might include one European web development
conference as well.
But that's okay.
I think custom properties have a huge potential
to change how we write and structure CSS,
and to a lesser extent as well, how we use
JavaScript to interact with UI components.
I will not focus as much on the syntax and
how they work.
What separates the best players of any game
is strategy.
I'm going to focus more on the strategies
today.
Can I get help?
I need a cursor.
So, custom properties are a little bit like
variables in preprocessors.
But they have some very important differences,
and one of the first and most obvious differences
is the syntax.
So, in Sass, we might have used a dollar sign
to denote a variable, and, in Less, we use
an @ symbol.
Custom properties use a dash-dash.
We use a different type of syntax for assigning
a value than we do for retrieving the value.
When retrieving the value, we use the va function
here, for anyone who has used things like
calc or the functional parts of CSS that are
making their way into the modern language.
The next most obvious difference is in the
same.
They are called custom properties because
they really are CSS properties.
In preprocessors, you can define the variable
almost anywhere.
This means outside declaration blocks, inside
media rules, you can even use them as part
of a selector, and all of those examples would
be invalid with custom properties.
Custom properties have the same rules about
where they can be used as normal CSS properties.
In fact, it is far better to think of them
as dynamic properties than it is to think
of them as variables.
This means that they can only be used inside
declaration blocks.
In other words, between these curly braces
here.
This means they are tied to a specific selector,
and that can be the root selector - you might
have seen this in a lot of examples - but
it can be any other valid CSS selector which
can include inside a media query.
So, similarly, you can retrieve the value
of a custom property anywhere you would normally
use a value in CSS.
So this means that they can be part of a single
value, or a shorthand statement, or they can
even be used inside calc next to other key
words and other values.
However, they can't be used inside media rules,
and they can't be used inside selectors, so
that means like Nth child are out which is
unfortunate.
That ends my crash course on custom properties.
There's probably a lot more that you want
to know about the syntax and how they work,
like how do we use fallback values and assign
custom properties to others, and the answer
to that one is yes, but this should be enough
of an understanding so that we can get to
know some of the other strategies we have
in this talk.
Cosmetic differences aside, one of the most
significant differences between variables
and preprocessors and custom properties is
how they are scoped.
We can refer to variables as statically or
dynamically scoped.
And preprocessors are static.
So where CSS is concerned, static means that
- static means we can update the value of
a variable at different points in the compilation
process, but we can't change the value of
the variables that came before it.
You can see, even though I'm using the same
variable name and targeting the same selector,
the output or generated CSS on this side is
going to be whatever the value was at that
time it was read.
This means that we could potentially read
an entire document css file without knowing
what the - and that's not something that we
can do with custom properties.
Custom properties work differently.
Where custom properties are concerned, dynamically
scoped means they're subject to inheritance
in the cascade.
It means this property is tied to a selector,
and, if the value changes, it affects all
matching DOM elements, like any other CSS
selector would.
This is great because it means that we can
update the value of a custom property using
a media query, a hover state, or a JavaScript,
and we don't have to change which custom property
we're using, just need to update its value
with CSS.
I want to show you a little bit of an example
of this which is why I was struggling to see
the cursor here before.
So, if I apply this example to my slides,
you can see that the heading colour is picked
up this light salmon which will affect all
of my slides, including the previous one there.
However, I can scope this to just slide 15
as well.
And you will see that none of the previous
slides are going to be affected any more.
In addition to being static or dynamic, variables
can be global or local.
If you write JavaScript, you will know what
I mean here.
Variables can be assigned to everything inside
an application, or their scope can be limited
to specific functions or blocks of code.
Custom properties are kind of similar.
So, custom properties are by fault locally
scoped to the selectors that we've applied
them to, so they're like local variables.
However, because custom properties are also
inherited, this means in many situations,
they can behave a lot like global variables
as well, especially if we're using them on
the root selector but they're kind of global.
When it comes to CSS, we have some things
that are global, and we want them applied
consistently across our application - things
like topography, spacing, colours - these
are all examples of you might want to apply
globally and consistently across your application.
This is a section from the Lonely Planet Style
Guide.
It contains things like the colour palettes
and the topography.
They have local things too.
So, for example, a button component.
That's in a section called "UI components",
and, when we use those terms would be , we're
often talking about local things.
There will be variables for these things too,
colour variations, the sizes we have for buttons.
All of these would be local variables.
This is something we are familiar with in
CSS as well.
We've created things like design systems,
style guides, naming conventions, JavaScript
libraries, all to help with dealing with this
problem of global sign elements, and isolating
them from local component concerns.
I think that custom properties now provide
some new opportunities for dealing with this
old problem.
So, as it turns out, most global things in
CSS are also static.
Your brand colours, your topography, don't
- typography don't change of from one component
to another.
Of course, these can change, but where it
does, it tends to be a global rebrand and
not something that happens very often on any
mature product.
And this is why I think it makes sense to
continue using a preprocessor for static variables.
So, aside from helping keep dynamic and static
concerns separate in the code, it visually
denotes static variables and this means that
you instantly know when something is going
to change globally, or when something sort
of more dynamic and local, and therefore we're
probably using a custom property.
This will make CSS a whole lot easier to read
and therefore easier to maintain.
There are a few small exceptions to this rule,
and one of them is client-side theming.
For the most part, I would call in a 90-per
cent rule, and one of the most important strategies
for working with custom properties effectively.
If you're taking notes, I can this is one
that you should possibly write down.
You might think that, given my strong stance
there on global variables being static, the
buy reflection, perhaps all local things should
be dynamic.
And whilst it's true that local variables
do tend to be dynamic, this is nowhere near
as strong as the tendency for global things
to be static, and, in many situations, it
makes a lot of sense still to have local variables
that are static or use preprocessors.
That's especially the case for more complex
UI components.
But of course, complex UI components don't
make great slides, so I've come up with a
fairly simple example here.
Again, I'm using the example of different
size variations for a button component.
I use variables like this mostly as a developer
convenience, and you can see I've got things
like button small, medium, and large.
And I prefixed those variables with the component
name so that I know that these are local variables
but you could use a different prefix, like
C for component, or L for local, with , or
even prefix global variables if you wanted
to.
Whatever you choose to do, I think it makes
sense to differentiate between local static
variables, or preprocessor variables, and
global static variables.
Now, if we take this simple example, and I
decide that I want all of the buttons to use
the small size on mobile devices or small
screens, we suddenly have a more dynamic sort
of situation here, and this is something that
means that custom properties possibly make
a lot more sense.
So luckily, we can assign preprocessor variables
to custom properties.
Now, you might be wondering what this hash
and curly braces around the variable are.
This is because $.button.small is a recent
value, and we need to interpolate these variables,
and tells Sass that you want to output the
variable and not $.button.small in the style
sheet.
This is needed where variables are valid CSS
or variable names are valid CSS.
Okay, so here you can see I've started off
with a button class and created a button property
with the size of button small.
That would be on all of those buttons there.
Using a media query above 600 pixels, I'm
changing the value of that custom property
to button large or medium, and I don't need
to change the small one because it stays the
same.
What this results this is static variables
becoming locally dynamic, so you can still
use a mix of two.
If you're refactoring, this is a pattern you
might want to consider.
Then finally here, you can see that I'm retrieving
the value of that custom property just in
one place, and, once again, it is only on
the button class which would be on all of
those buttons.
Yet it's going to have a different value,
depending on the conditions above.
Okay, so just a little deviation here.
Hands up anyone who has written an overly
complexion Sass abstraction only to get their
hands burnt?
A few people.
A few people who have gone back to using Sass
for variables?
That describes my experience initially, and
I read a really interesting block post on
this topic recently, on the free code camp,
saying don't do it at run time but do it at
design time, by Bill Sawyer, and he gave this
example here.
This is really clever.
What it does is creates an array of letters
of the alphabet by looping over different
character codes and pushing them into the
array.
Obviously, it is like a really nice concise
bit of code, smaller, go going to be faster
than writing out all of those values by hand
but I agree with the author.
The alphabet is not likely to change.
And I want to see what is in that array.
So code like this, whilst clever, isn't necessarily
helpful in a production setting.
The dynamic nature of custom properties allows
us to create clever and complicated abstractions.
This example here generates a modular scale.
A modular scale is like a series of numbers
that relate to each other with a given ratio,
and they're often used for things lying heading
and font sizes, and spacing, in web design.
And I could talk a whole lot about modular
scales and how we might use them.
In this talk, the modular scale is generated
at run time using custom properties, and the
ratio there.
The value of each of these is calculated using
that ratio and the value of the custom property
that came before it.
What this means is we can change the ratio,
and all of those custom properties are going
to be recalculated live in the browser at
run time.
Custom properties shouldn't be and won't be
immune to this experimentation and innovation.
We did it with preprocessors as well.
In the long run, I think that readable, maintainable
code, is going to win over clever abstraction
s like this, at least in production.
In production, I might like to see something
a little bit more like this.
Here I can easily read what the value of each
of those custom properties is going to be.
This is good.
Because we recode many more times than we
write it.
Once I figured out what I think these values
should be, it's not likely that these are
going to change of in my application.
That's why I think it makes sense to generate
code like this at design time.
Of course, this example here can still be
improved.
It violates the rule earlier that sort of
all global variables should be static, and
I consider these fairly global.
I would much prefer to make these pro processor
variables and then convert them to locally
dynamic custom properties as required, using
the technique that I showed you before with
the buttons.
I think that is also important to avoid situations
where we name custom properties like this
- font size 1, 2, et cetera, because this
can result in a situation where we go from
using one custom property to a different custom
property.
That brings me to my next strategy.
That is change the value, not the variable.
Once again, this is one of the most important
strategies for working with custom properties
effectively: if you're taking notes, perhaps
underline that one.
So, unfortunately, I see a lot of examples
like this with custom properties.
Here we have two custom properties, one called
font size small, one called font size large,
and then using a media query, I'm switching
from using the small to the large one.
This is exactly how we would have done things
with preprocessors, but with custom properties,
this doesn't make a great deal of sense.
So, with custom properties, a far better way
to do this would be to define a single custom
property, and we zero that to the component,
and in this case, it is the example component.
As a general rule, we should never change
which custom property we're using for any
single purpose.
So, with the media query, I'm updating the
value of the same custom property here.
Then once again, in a single place, I'm retrieving
the value of that custom property.
And you will notice that the media query here
is only used to change the value of the custom
property, not to retrieve that value.
And there's very good reasons why I've done
this, and you will see this pattern again
throughout my talk, and it brings me to my
next set of strategies which is for responsive
design.
So, one of the problems with responsive design
when it relies heavily on media queries is
that, no matter how we organise our CSS, all
of the styles relating to particular components
become fragmented across the style sheet,
and it can be difficult to know which CSS
properties are going to change.
So custom properties can help us organise
some of this logic related to responsive design
and make working with media queries a whole
lot easier.
So, my first strategy for responsive design
is if it changes, it's a variable.
What I mean by this is if you're using a media
query or a hover state to update the value
of a CSS property, perhaps you should replace
this in a custom property and move it along
with a selector and the media query whatever
else changes its value up to the top of the
document.
If done correctly, this means that media queries
will only be used to update the value of custom
properties.
As a result of that, we will have a clear
separation of logic from its implementation.
This means that all the logic will be at the
top of the do you mean, and wherever we see
a vast statement, we immediately know that
this is something that changes in our CSS,
and with traditional methods of writing CSS,
there's no way of knowing this.
It creates a link between logic and its implementation,
and I find that incredibly useful.
So the idea of declaring variables at the
top of a document is not a new idea, it's
something we've done in many programming languages,
and it's something we do with preprocessors
instinctively, and it's something we can do
with regular CSS as well.
So, writing CSS in this way creates a clear
distinction between the CSS at the top of
the document and the CSS below.
And I need a way to differentiate between
these sections when I talk about them, so
I've come up with this metaphor of logic fold.
Above the fold contains all the custom properties,
and the selectors that might change those
values, and, below the fold, it's highly declarative
and straightforward and easy to read, and,
in fact, it feels like the kind of CSS we
used to write some years ago before media
queries and other complexities of the modern
language.
So this is what it might look like above the
fold.
As you can see here, this section only contains
custom properties, and more than that, it
only contains examples where we're assigning
values to custom properties, not retrieving
them.
You might have figured out this is for a basic
six-column Flexbox grid system and I have
a Flexbox there called row display, and using
media query, updating the value from block
to flex, so all of those custom properties
will come into effect.
So, below the fold, I can see which CSS properties
are going to be changed.
I know that the row classes using the row
display one, and for the display report, which
isn't surprising, and I can see that the value
used for the flex basis and what is interesting
is the value of that custom property will
be different depending on which of the classes
is applied in the HTML.
And it can make CSS like that a lot less verbose.
We only need the one place where we are defining
the styles, and I can look back above the
fold, and I can see what those values are
going to be in the different situations that
might exist within the browser.
So, writing CSS in this way is easy to maintain
because all of the logic is in one place,
and all the declarative code is somewhere
else.
It's easy to read because we know what is
changing.
Anything without reading and interpreting
the whole style sheet, as many of us have
become good at doing, and what it will result
is all the styles and design concerns being
in one place for each individual component,
and separating the logic from the implementation
like this is again another important strategy
for working effectively with custom properties.
Of course, all rules are meant to be broken,
and that brings me to my next set of strategies
for theming.
So, throughout this talk, there are a lot
of places where I've already argued against
using custom properties for sort of global,
dynamic variables, and hopefully, I've implied
that assigning custom properties to the root
selector is in many cases considered harmful,
but like I said, every rule has an exception,
and for the custom properties, it is theming,
and I think that limited use of global dynamic
variables for theming makes it a lot of sense.
So theming generally refers to updating the
UI in some way, could be something like the
Twitter profile page here, changing the colours,
the background image of a profile picture,
et cetera.
Or it could also be something more localised,
so, for example, changing the colour of a
note in Google Keep application, or you might
have used a similar note-keeping application
like that.
Theming usually involves compiling a separate
style sheet for user preferences and this
can be difficult.
It is not very performant because it means
we might be re-rendering the page in many
situations.
So, with custom properties, we don't compile
the separate style sheets, all we need to
do is put the user variables or the user custom
property up on the root selector, and these
can be inherited by the default style sheet.
So, Ida and Dag will show you practical examples
later on.
I think that we should be very deliberate
and considerate about the use of custom properties
when it comes to theming, because these global
dynamic variables can be a lot harder to maintain,
but lately, custom properties are case-sensitive,
and since most of our custom properties are
going to be local, if we're using dynamic
global custom properties, it can make sense
to capitalise them.
So, capitalisation of variables often signifies
global constants, and for us, this is going
to signify that the value of the custom property
might be set somewhere else in the application,
and we probably should not change it locally.
I think that it can be useful to avoid directly
overriding these global theme values, and
that's why I've used an example like this.
Here I'm setting the value of theme colour
to the value of user theme colour, if it exists,
and then this value here is a fallback value
for when the user theme colour doesn't exist.
So, if we're using theme colour throughout
our application, it's going to fall back nicely
whenever the user has not set that preference.
So I want to show you a quick example of this.
Here, I've set the value of the background
to theme colour, and if I apply this to my
slides, the background colour is going to
change.
Now, I want you to have a think about what
will happen when using a theme colour available
in the body here.
The answer might surprise you, that we are
still falling back to this default value here,
and the reason for that value is the value
of the user theme colour has been set on the
root element, and that's where we are this
value is free from.
So, obviously, when I move through the [ ...]. That
can be a useful pattern if you want to avoid
people from overriding these global values
in different places in your application.
Also, something a bit more complicated, it
can be helpful sometimes to expose those variables
with a star selector.
This makes the theme colour custom property
on every element, and then that means that
it is recalculated for the body element and
we're able to pick you want value of that
user theme colour.
I'm going to delete that and put my slides
back to the normal colour.
Okay, so, if you want to set the value of
custom properties with JavaScript, there's
a fairly simple API, and it looks a little
bit like this.
I'm setting the theme colour to tomato, doing
it on the document element there which is
the equivalent of the root element.
One of the really cool things about this is,
if you have a technical design team, you can
assign these variables up on the root element
there, and then they can decide how they should
be used throughout the style sheet, and this
allows you to make large changes to how theming
works in your application without having to
touch any backend code and without necessarily
having to touch any JavaScript, so that can
be really useful as well before if you're
- as well.
If you're using a static site generator, or
something like React or vue, you can write
these custom properties out to style attributes
as well, and these are going to have greater
specificity than any defaults in the style
sheets, so these values are likely to be picked
up if used correctly.
It's like a component-level thing except the
props are passed through the style attributes,
and I've seen it used for things like getting
multi-coloured icons with SVG, and a whole
lot of tricks you can do with this pattern,
and I'm a big fan of that.
So the final strategy I have for you is to
started using custom properties today.
Even if you're supporting IE10 and 11, you
can start using some of these techniques.
So much of what I've been talking about today
is how we write and structure CSS, and this
means that we can use tools like post-CSS
to write this out to a static representation
of the same code.
I use a tool called post-CSS variables, and
I know it is a little bit confusing but not
post-CSS variables and not post-CSS custom
properties, the reason for that is am so of
those libraries can't determine what the custom
properties will be inside media queries and
other things, they treat them custom properties
a lot like static variables, or a lot like
preprocessor variables, but that first one
will do a better job of that.
Obviously, this technique won't be able to
do some of the dynamic things, like some of
the theming examples that I've talked about,
but that might be okay.
It might be perfectly acceptable for older
browsers to fall back to a default theme,
and you apply theming and customisation and
a progressive enhancement.
If you want to know more about the specific
techniques I use for generating this, come
and talk to me afterwards because I don't
have time to go into the build process.
I know what you're thinking here.
Mike, this is great, but I haven't been listening.
Could you give me the whole talk again in
one sentence?
Yes, I can!
It comes down to understanding the difference
between dynamic and static variables in CSS,
and, a few simple rules.
Global variables are usually static, separate
logic from design.
If a CSS changes, it might be a custom property,
and change the value, not which custom property
is used.
If you follow these conventions, you might
find that working with custom properties is
a whole lot easier than you think, and it
might even change how you approach CSS in
general, and, yes, that was one sentence and
I can't use a full stop.
If you have any questions, please come and
see me.
There are other examples that I would love
to show people.
Thanks very much for your time!
[Applause]